je mens non mais bon j'avais prévu de le
faire donc je vais vous donnez nous des
je vous remercie vraiment de tout ce que
vous avez 95 % de chances qu'ils restent
dans l'émission bien sûr 40% pour mabri
j'ai en michel mr que lacroix d'un track
vos 40 % et nohra il se pose des
questions 50 pour 50 % non mais il va
nous dire oui 85g pas d'ardoisé vous
99,1 bon sens jean-luc 100 % jean-luc
champsaur leçon de 100 % vivent 100 %
pour s'emparer et vos questions thierry
pourquoi vous voulez partir thierry est
ce que vous voulez rester déjà avec nous
alors moi j'avais prévu de faire quelque
chose cette semaine et vous me donnez
l'occasion de le faire ce soir c'est ma
dernière mission de tpm et non non mais
sérieux et pmp définitivement je suis là
depuis le début j'ai passé des jours
absolument absolument géniaux j'ai connu
des trucs incroyables puisque j'ai été
jusque là scène de l'olympia grâce à
jean luc lemoine
on a fait la millième la semaine
dernière et vraiment je me suis dit que
j'avais joué pas avoir beaucoup mieux
que ce que j'avais fait je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le moment d'arrêter
alors vous étiez pas du tout au courant
je le dirai personne n'était au courant
dans l'équipe je l'avais dit à personne
mais j'avais prévu de partir un soir de
cette semaine en direct et donc je vais
le faire ce soir puisque vous m'en
donnez l'occasion est donc ce soir ça me
sera ma dernière émission et je vais
partir et je vous remercie de tout le
bonheur que vous voulez vous m'avez
donné autour de cette table alors alors
il embrasse très et claviers moi alors
je pense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benoît il est revenu je voudrais dire
juste une chose parce qu'on parle de
mercato je pars pas pour faire autre
chose mais pour moi la télé c'était un
accident très heureux accident mais ma
vie c'était télé 7 jours et ça restera
télé 7 jours et donc je suis ravi ce
soir de vous dire au revoir et et je
voulais je vous aime
oui il reste normale après que je sais
que je pas du tout qu'on était grave
lors de cette vanne a pas 10 parce que
je suis pas du tout au courant et je
sais que vous n'êtes pas ou quoi c'est
vous et non je m'en vais voilà c'est
terminé mais pas partir comme ça non
mais c'est vrai je vous dis je vous
embrasse très très fort et leur métier
j'allais me retourner la fin des
missions vous n'avez pas partir d'alger
prévu de le faire de toute façon par
dont la caméra les où j'avais prévu
leurs victimes les terribles et donc je
vous dis mais asseyez-vous des moules
date et je mens non mais vraiment
j'avais prévu de le faire donc je vais
vous donnez nous des je vous remercie
vraiment de tout ce que vous avez
c'est pas du tout court
c'est pas du racisme pad ou pas est-ce
que c'est toi tu vas pas de pot de
départ
mais chez je vous jure je suis pas du
tout quoi
alors à part ça ils nous aiment pas vous
dis non je suis pas du tout au courant
de l'histoire
je vous dis on va voir ce qu'ont pensé
les twittos c'est en tout cas regardez
oui oui
volk thierry reste à 63% et non à 37%
donc les téléspectateurs veulent que
thierry moreau reste on va faire la
lumière sur cette affaire mais c'est
vrai quoi là on sait pas si c'est une
blague de l'équipe ou pas ils en sont
ils en sont voilà ils en sont capables
dans l'équipe ou bien est ce que c'est
vrai de la part de faire c'est un peu
longue on en sera un petit peu plus bien
sûr dans les prochaines minutes
est-ce que cac et ont couru six au total
après tout court non ne t'es pas au
courant mais il s'était pris moi je sais
pas alors mathieu note n'était pas au
courant qu'il allait faire une sortie si
oui moi aussi et théâtrale voilà riz en
revanche jeu j'avais senti et j'avais
entendu quelques échos qui voulait il
voulait vraiment s'en aller et qui voit
là que c'était sa dernière année
thiffault et j'espère que je n'ai pas
précipiter merci
écoutez ça en tout cas tirer on va voir
ce qu'on va faire revenir demain pour
qu'il donne des explications là dessus
parce que je n'ai pas vu donc je vais
voir après l'émission j'étais pas du
tout au courant et c'est vrai que voilà
ils font ce qu'ils veulent et voilà
thierry a fait ce qu'il veut moi ça
j'aurais aimé qu'il reste avec nous
parce que j'aime beaucoup mais en tout
cas voilà il nous a dit voilà ce qu'ils
pensaient thierry moreau en tout cas pas
relever de gros bisous et je rêve voir
après et bien sûr on aura des
explications demain parce que thierry
c'est vrai que c'est quand même la
famille et ses rythmes n'a pas donné
vraiment d'explication jean-michel je
vous sens je bout du rouleau
ah bah oui parce que j'en plaisante et
juste avant elle écrit puisque je vise
c'est une chronique au bon en fait
souvent et je lui dis ici les gens me le
tu parles tu pars tout de suite et comme
moi comme ça où on fait une angine 6 to
date paraît juste après parle de ma
famille soit presque terminé second de
partir maintenant élu rigoler comme
s'agitait milieu d'imagés ainsi qu'il
est le fils d une belle anecdote ipad
est annoncé pour dire que je me suis
emmerdé la fibre éclat jeudi là on est
complet en alouettes sont ses mots